come on I gotta say I haven't seen you
in a little while you look fantastic you
very much man thanks I lost fifty pounds
fifty pound everyone wants to know how
one does that because everyone's
obsessed
what was your trick everybody's been I
was in a weight loss contest with this
super fat comic named burnt Chrysler and
what we did was we did we we asked
people to fat shameless publicly which
when you give people the green light to
call you fat they do not hold back and
and it actually works because I would be
like oh I'm gonna be in st. Louis this
week and I would tweet that and then
people would be like will there be any
food left by the time you leave so then
you that you would ask for this she
would brought it on I brought it on
myself
I even today I worked out because I was
like imma do Conan and then somebody
wrote did they reinforce the stage so
you can sit there and so like but it
works cuz they so you have to embrace it
like it doesn't work for everybody but
if you sign up for it but getting this
level of hate shot at you and derision
that seems to work for you yeah yeah if
like if you I mean I'm telling you you
can call me fat it's fine
okay I'm used to it by now all right
well I won't do that but I'm glad that
it's working for you and I'm glad a lot
of other people are calling you fat uh
hundreds of thousand
you